vous avez appris le décès de votre fils
alors selon une source policière il
aurait volontairement sauté d'un parapet
en béton haut de 20 mètres et pour ses
proches
la thèse du suicide est difficile à
croire bernard on peux pas le croire
c'est une étude d'une évidence il sauf
ils avaient tous étaient heureux ils
étaient se régaler d'un ses business
sensibles dont celui ci ne s'est pas
assez c'est impossible quoi c'est
possible ou alors comme giuly sort il ya
une chose qui nous a échappé mais pour
moi c'était possible et puis je vous
assure que je ne reviendrai jamais cette
idée là c'est tellement plus chic non
mais quand quand vous dites c'est
impossible bernard quel est l'autre
hypothèse alors penser que c'est un
accident qu'il aurait glissé qu'il
aurait oui il se donnait un parapet et
moi j'aime moi dans ma tête je me dis
c'est à bougie de quoi il a glissé ces
deux thèmes possibles effets moi je
l'avais eu encore d'autres jours avant
sa peau c'est pas possible dans ma tête
ce n'est pas possible alors voilà il ya
des choses que je savais pas c'est pas
possible c'est encore une fois quand tu
voyais la vidéo de ce garçon plein plein
d'énergie même s'il avait des moments
difficiles à christophe allen c'est vrai
que quand janot vous a dit qu'il acquit
la plaie il faut savoir que janot et
nicole ils ont perdu leur première fille
et les enfants d'été nationale et les
parents d'ados christophe qu'ils ont
déjà perdu leur première question qu'ils
réclamaient moi j'ai appris que ça
l'avait bouleversé
c'est la science qui sophie la vidéo il
avait des bas mais pas à ce point là ma
tête je me dis je ne veux pas y croire
alors on va on va parler lille et on va
parler de la teste j'entends jean dire
depuis tout à l'heure
non je vous posais la même question on
passe à la dernière
et jean vous depuis tout à l'heure quand
bernard dit c'est un accident dit non
pensez que c'est quoi alors est ce que
dit c'est un site c'est pas un accident
ça je dis pas pour moi pour moi il s'est
pacifié il avait passé notre mauvaise
nuit
il avait il avait une grande impression
donc il était il est en procès présent
il vous le disais ça y est vous elle
était il avait une dépression dans l'été
ils devenus passat est devenu passé
trois mois avec avec nous je les soigne
on y adonner la bd casher parmi les
prenez j'étais bien là le mieux
il a voulu remonter son pari et là elle
ne sait pas la psy qui le soigne qu'est
ce qu'elle lui a donné
qu'est ce qu'il ya comment elle a voulu
le soigner parce qu'il n'était pas dans
son état normal n'était pas bien et noir
où je me révolte c'est que pour des
maladies comme ça ce n'est pas elle est
déjà enterré en vidéo nation mais je
pense que déjà cette personne a redit se
déranger pour le soigner sa psy le
suivre oui et si ça n'allait pas le
faire entrer dans une clinique et cette
nuit là il avait passé une très mauvaise
nuit alors je sais pas le matin il va y
mènent les enfants ses filles à l'école
avec sa femme la plus grande
[Musique]
je commence par vous dire papa maritime
est bon et il rentre à la maison
il avait mal dormi il dit à sa femme
toute la nuit j'ai eu ma semblait comme
ont tiré dessus gt gt pas bien j'ai des
passé une très mauvaise nuit